you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 news now and
unfortunately Heather
it may be very cloudy so we may not may
not have a chance to see much of it
anyway we do have some clouds right now
this is a beautiful picture our camera
at the Sunset Station way down to the
Southeast Valley looking all the way
across at the strip and if you look
closely here you see some of the snow
that dusted up there now up at League
Canyon over on the other side they've
got four inches of snow 56 the official
number ought to read International but
we always want to know what's happening
where you are hanging on to 50 right now
out at the lake Summerlin 49 still not
even 40 up at Kyle Canyon the Air Force
Base 55 same with the strip and also in
Henderson now these numbers are a few
degrees warmer than yesterday we are
going to warm it up again for the next
day or so but those much cooler
temperatures and even more wind are
coming back next week some more right
now numbers uh Death Valley you're at 69
over the humping profits 51. it's been
getting down to the teens in Ely and
Cedar City now all the watches and
warnings are done for now but we're
expecting that there will be more we're
going to try for 6 60 some neighborhoods
will do better than that normal high 73
and it was on this day just a couple of
years ago 2020 we got up to 86 degrees
on November the 4th that's not happening
this time around so we're keeping it out
for the next system for Sunday Monday
and Tuesday the system that we just got
rid of you see this red there's a
potential for tornado outbreaks through
much of Oklahoma and the North Central
Texas otherwise these are showers and
thunderstorms for the folks in the upper
Great Lakes all the way down through the
central plains now your most accurate
eight-day forecast so enjoy 66 tomorrow
don't forget to set the clocks back that
don't automatically do it on Saturday
night into Sunday 70. for Sunday but
that's going to be about it we tumble
again chances for rain Monday night and
maybe election day Tuesday and very
windy high temperatures slipping back to
the 50s and maybe lows in the upper 30s
next week Heather
oh boy